halo infinite push to 2021 and you're
gonna have to cough up a little extra
buns if you want to play control on ps5
or series x i'm lucy and welcome to
generation next
gamespot's dedicated show all about the
ps5
and xbox series x each week we'll be
diving deep
into all the biggest news stories as
well as just getting excited
for the brand new consoles i'm joined by
playstation pro tomorrow hussein
absolutely gushing with excitement for
next-gen consoles gushing
i am upset and xbox expert jordan
remains
up really
to more that's what you want to that's
how we're going to introduce
this is the our first ever episode
and you know couldn't have happened in a
more quiet week for news lying liars and
the lies they tell
okay lying cat from
the comic book series saga which is very
good uh yeah
totally lying it has been a huge week
for xbox so jordan i'm gonna come to you
for the news
first all right kind of split this xbox
story into two parts the first of which
is that
we finally have a more concise release
date for xbox series x
the fact that instead of just holiday
2020 we now know it's coming in november
2020 and i assume that's
probably going to correlate to something
like november
17th or something there with so that
they can use something like assassin's
creed valhalla
and chris tales as quote unquote launch
titles
and they can say something like oh you
want to play cyberpunk 2077
we'll play it on the best console xbox
series x a
nice little marketing stunt that they
can do right before the big holiday
shopping season but the more surprising
bit of news on the xbox eyes is the fact
that
halo infinite has been delayed so sirius
x doesn't have this huge
launch title for its system anymore now
halo infinite's coming in 2021
so tam do you think that series x can
still do well like can it launch in a
good place even without halo infinite
first of all a little peek behind the
curtain i totally knew this was going to
happen to the point where
when the story broke like i published
our story maybe like
five seconds after because i already had
yeah it's my fault but i had already
written a halo infinite is gonna be
delayed story maybe like four months ago
so i just like
dug up that duck and i was like here you
are buddy and like put it out there
so i think that nostra thomas over here
that's your thomas
i mean i'll take it i'll take it it
works it works it works better written
down yeah it does it definitely does
um i will say it is going to be a huge
blow for microsoft um
not having a halo on the launch of a
brand new xbox console i think
it will still be fine but the dividends
that would have paid would have been
massive
um looking at it from a glass half full
perspective i think that there's an
opportunity for really microsoft to kind
of play up the importance of their
services
and really show how meaningful they can
be
they need to start off by making sure
the other titles definitely hit
which i'm sure that they will they
probably have a few cooking that we just
don't know about yet um
or they're shifting things around to
make it happen but more importantly
i think that puts a greater pressure on
them to make sure that game pass is as
attractive as it can be to newcomers who
are purchasing the console it's already
in a good position we call it the you
know the best deal in gaming for
for good reason but every week that goes
by without a halo
is another justification for microsoft
to kind of
open up their wallets and you know pay
for bigger bigger
uh titles or more attractive titles for
game pass so i i think that they need to
really put an emphasis on those services
specifically game pass to show
why the xbox series x is attractive to
people beyond
the lack of a halo game so my hope is
phil
sponsors phil sponsors some big titles
for uh game pass wait phil sponsor out
here
is that his new name phil sponsors i
call him when he's working on game pass
he's called phil sponsor
i like how you pause because you realize
what you had said
that was that was entirely intentional
you have to pause for dramatic effect
like i'm i i'm just as sad as everyone
else that halo is not
going to be a launch title for the
series x ultimately i think it would be
more damaging
to them if it launched and it wasn't in
the state um
obviously there was a little bit of
backlash a lot of internet chatter about
the screens they released about the
gameplay that we saw obviously craig
has become well he's stolen my heart i
don't know about yours
so like that is a shame but ultimately i
can understand it
i mean is it gonna be enough though i'll
put this question to you both was like
we know we're gonna get a series x right
but if you are on the fence
what does this series x have that's
really going to push you to buy it
if you know now that halo slipped are
you going to buy it for this holiday
season
or i don't know i i'm interested to see
what they've got at their sleeves
obviously we have
the the mysterious series s
um that leaked through that controller
pack leak the other day
um xbox are releasing uh the off rumored
lower spec
xbox series x called the series s
this is going to get confusing at some
point it's getting between 1s
1x series x and series s
but also if your diction is not good you
could accidentally mispronounce
um so i'm just very interested to see
how the rest of the year goes for xbox i
hope this isn't
such a huge blow for them but like like
tam said you've got phil sponsors there
he's ready he's ready to sponsor some
games
i call him big phil but i'm more than
happy to revert and call him
big phil i call him big bill yeah big
phoenix
that's what no i couldn't be phil
because
um oh do we want to go down this this
path already
you've opened the path you've started
walking you've got to finish the journey
uh there are some dating videos from
like a
mail-in tape service from the 80s and
there's this guy
who says hi my name is phil uh most my
friends call me big phil
so every time i hear phil spencer i can
it doesn't even look like the same guy
but every time in my head i just
automatically get the ping of
my my name's phil my friends called me
big phil so i refer to phil spencer's
big phil which i'm sure he appreciates
all right tam playstation uh nothing
specific to playstation so this is more
of a story that kind of has implications
for a bunch of um
across all platforms really long and
short story of it is
control is getting an ultimate edition
um it's launching for 40
on steam and then a ps4 and xbox one
version of that game will be available
control is also going to get a ps5 and
xbox one
x dammit xbox series xc um
xbox series x upgrade however the only
way for you to get that upgrade
is if you purchase the new ultimate
edition so effectively you need to buy
a new version of control if you want the
upgraded version for next-gen consoles
currently we asked
uh remedy and 505 and they said owners
of the base game and dlc as of control
as it stands are not eligible for an
upgrade
that doesn't stop them from putting out
like a upgrade dlc
pack for a cheaper price later but we
there's no confirmation of that
happening
um obviously not the most
consumer-friendly move um
especially as other studios and games
and companies are giving free upgrades
but i think it's important to also get
some perspective on remedy as a studio
it's
not all um financial considerations are
the same across studios and remedy is a
studio that i like to say
constantly punches above their weights
wait they put out games that are like
super
aaa really critically acclaimed and
they've earned the prestige studio kind
of monika
and and kind of like reputation and so
the expectation on them is higher
but that might not necessarily be what
they're able to achieve from a financial
situation
remedy isn't a huge team relatively
speaking it partners with publishers
like 505 and microsoft to get things
done
but the financial implications on them
aren't
like as aren't the same in the way that
they are for someone like this
the destiny developer bungie um my hope
is that the publisher 505 games sees the
the kind of uh commentary around it the
backlash to it
and steps in and foots the bill for that
or remedy is able to come to some sort
of agreement or even microsoft steps up
it's like we'll pay for your xbox series
x upgrade
um just do it for us or maybe sony is
the same
that's my hope anyway or at the very
least they do that dlc upgrade that is
like cheap and attractive
as a price point um jordan do you have
any interest in playing
uh control on the ps5 or xbox series x
and
would you reckon about about that price
well i would never say that i'm not
above playing control again one it's an
excellent game and
two i think if i ever said anything
negative about control
like chris p and phil would somehow some
way like track me down
and and no i was gonna say another
another peak behind the curtain at
gamespot is
whenever a new game comes out we make a
slack channel for it to help coordinate
coverage
share tips and stuff as we're all
playing uh they usually get closed down
a few months after the game is launched
and no one's really playing it anymore
talking about it
the control slack channel never closed
it's still
active we post gifts of dr darling in
there
yeah it's still going yeah every few
weeks you just get a little notification
a reminder that control is still an
excellent game
so yes i have no problem with buying
control a second time and i'm really not
at all
surprised that at least someone is
doing this like we remember like with
the playstation 4 and
xbox one like during that console uh
generational change there were moments
like assassin's creed 4 black flag where
it came out for 360 and you could play
it backwards compatible
on the xbox one but if you wanted those
like
higher def graphics however minor the
difference it was you had to actually
buy the xbox one
version of the game and this is
essentially the same
thing with control like you have the old
version
you can play it on playstation 5 and
xbox series x when they
come out and if you want the newer
version then you gotta buy it i'm
actually a little surprised that we
haven't heard
more developers announce that this is
the way they're going to handle
smart delivery or whatever playstation
5's version of
this is going to be i think i was very
surprised that it was control
to be the first one to come out of the
gate um and reveal that they were going
to be charging because they were in
they've been in showcases very recently
like the alan wake expansion
was in the microsoft showcase a few
weeks ago but i also think
you know sony hasn't necessarily
detailed what their
um you know next-gen hop-up so to speak
is going to be microsoft have been
talking about smart delivery but i think
they're also making concessions
for select publishers obviously they
want to get the cyberpunk in there they
want to get assassin's creed in there
if a new call of duty gets announced
which it seems like it is going to be i
imagine
they will be the same they'll be the
same because
and i don't mean this in any horrible
way because i think remedy are a
fantastic studio
i think they make incredible games i
absolutely adore control
is control a system seller that's the
question you have to ask cyberpunk
is a system seller assassin's creed a
system seller
and so i really hope we just don't get
into a place where
you know double a indie developers
are having to charge again and it's seen
as anti-consumer
but it's because they're not afforded
the same concessions that
these blockbuster triple a's are getting
so
it'll be interesting to see how this
pattern continues
but all of this talk about control
and you know great games got me thinking
well we've got this nice little fallow
period um
a few weeks where not that much is
coming out in terms of these big
blockbuster aaa's and we're all just
patiently waiting for the next
generation
of consoles so what better time
to revisit some of the best games from
the ps4
and xbox one so we've each brought
a favorite uh i am difficult
so i've brought a multi-platform one but
tam and jordan both have a
platform exclusive so tam i'm gonna come
to you first
what is the game that every ps4 owner
should play while they're waiting for
the ps5
we could cut this entire portion and you
see that i know what tan would say you
see that bad boy
that's bloodborne baby everyone should
be playing bloodborne
firstly i just want a slight tangent
who uses fallow in a sentence growing up
secondly
um uh blub on is the best
ps4 exclusive unless you work out kind
of funny and have bad opinions
that's what most
shots fired always um but yeah
i think it's pretty well established
that bloodborne is probably
among the premier ps4 exclusives and
if for some reason you haven't played it
um
i still think that a lot of people have
this kind of idea that it's for a
certain
type of person because they've seen what
dark souls is and what you know
um those kind of souls like games are i
feel like this is
that's kind of hampered people's uh
interest in getting into bloodborne
bloodborne's a very different type of
game
it looks and can feel the same but what
it requires from you and how it feeds
back the things that it's doing in terms
of design is completely different to
dark souls
so even if you might have been dissuaded
from playing those games because they're
too hard or
they feel like they're a lot give
bloodborne a try because it's
it's so different from those when you
really get into the nitty-gritty of it
and it's immediately interesting the
world is amazing
and like there's not many games that i
get obsessed with on this degree like i
i literally think about it every day um
and like i'm not the kind of person who
would define their personality based on
fictional things but
bloodborne maybe batman maybe i was
gonna say hang on can we get a meme
made up of uh friendship ended with
metal gear solid five
ah listen solid five best friends metal
gear solid five is the greatest stealth
game ever made
um but bloodborne is just one of the
greatest games ever made
period [ __ ] i mean he's not wrong he's
not wrong
he's not wrong yeah so why should why
should people play it
um give give us like the
going into the next gen why do people
have to experience
this particular game i i think like the
obviously as you said earlier
sony's um plans for the next gen hop up
as you called it which i like very much
um that was for you both because
tam and i played apex together i know
jordan loves it but jordan plays on
different
i mean it's the best battle royale game
of all time but that's neither here or
there we're talking about bloodborne
true um yeah i mean like there's no
guarantee that bloodborne will make it
to the ps5 i think if sony doesn't
include some sort of upgrade path for
for bloodborne they'll grow up mark
cerny
um but like i don't think you should
wait for ps5 to make it you know but
decide you want to play blah blah blah
is phenomenal right now it's distinct
there's nothing else like it in
existence
like in in no game it comes close you
have souls likes but very few can come
close to like how expertly crafted this
game is
whether it's the gameplay the story the
characterization the
the kind of like the ambience and the
mood the feel that the game puts
you know puts you in and when you play
and you go into yarn
it's like a singular experience and it's
the more you go into it the more you
realize how amazing it is
to quote you know master willem grant us
eyes and play the game and you will be
granted eyes
so you will see the truth of the
playstation exclusive catalogue
in that this is the best one i don't
really remember that
particular voice line uh maybe i didn't
do that side quest but before i move on
to
your eyes are yet to open lucy to jordan
you you technically you said that apex
is the best battle royale but we're
talking about bloodborne
well technically can't you can't you
kill everyone in bloodborne so doesn't
it make
bloodborne of battle royale
standing lucy i'm about to break social
distancing so we can throw hands don't
you
you live like an hour and a half away
from me
it's fine but you know food for thought
jordan before we continue i would like
to issue a correction it was
mikalash who actually says i apologize
to
everyone else there may i was going to
say
someone's got to play blackboard again i
think it's great
cancellation you would have had you've
got that wrong
jordan i'm going to come to you what is
the your favorite xbox one game
that you think people may have missed
it's got to be sunset overdrive
and largely because i think it
represents like the best
part of when xbox was really behind
highlighting unique creative ideas and
they've they still kind of do that like
they have their idea at xbox and whatnot
and i really like the indie games that
they
have offered but they haven't done
anything like
truly unique or remarkable with a triple
a game in like a really long time and
like i remember like early on in the
xbox one's career and they would have
games that weren't so good like quantum
break and then ones that were
pretty good like titanfall which was an
awesome like xbox one console exclusive
and then you had stuff like sunset
overdrive
which was this beautiful like melding of
combat and navigation where you would be
jumping on cars and grinding on lines
and
while running across buildings shooting
zombies and having like this really
silly time with all these like
incredibly unique weapons and it had
this
incredible style all its own that you
didn't really
see in any other games especially games
that had
stuff like parkour like assassin's creed
and tomb raider and whatnot
and it was so good and i loved it so
much and i always
look back on them like man xbox is like
one of their biggest mistakes of this
generation is letting
insomniac get away with them and taking
that amazing
combination of navigation and combat and
using that to create an amazing
spider-man
game but like sunset overdrive that's
that's where it was at and i loved it so
much it was
the brief moment when it came out was
when i was like
okay okay xbox has this they can come
back they'll have plenty of excellent
first party console exclusives and then
the like dark times of late 2014
to what was it 2017 happened
and i'm not even sure we're out of it
yet but sunset is great and everyone
should play that
i just want to say that i appreciate
your impassioned speech for sunset
overdrive
but tam your mic is picking up the
buttons man
i can see you playing i can see you
playing bloodborne no
not in a bad way i just i just really
want evan
editing voice of god i just need you to
slowly zoom in on time screen i could
see him you had the whirly gig you were
going through the menus and i was like
if he does a boss like not even looking
at the screen
looking at it reflected that is the
biggest power play
i've ever seen i i just killed jordan to
talk about sunset overdrive tam can just
beat mikalish i think i think sunset
just represents something really great
about xbox it was this fun
colorful experiment and hopefully you
know you see flashes of it like you said
in id at xbox games
hopefully with a new fable just a bit of
i don't know something different
something with attitude um
so i hope i hope we get to see more of
that um coming up
over the next few months with some more
games but my my choice
like i said because i'm difficult
multi-platform game because i can't
choose um is dishonored 2 so the reason
i picked dishonored 2
for like a game that you might have
missed from this generation
is because i i love dishonored 2. i love
dishonored
but i think 2 is this great moment
where you can see the seeds for future
arcane games and i think in particular
where that lies is death loop obviously
definitely coming to playstation first
but it will become an xbox eventually
you can see you know incredible level
design within dishonored 2 i think
cracking the slab
and obviously the clockwork mansion two
of the greatest and most fun levels in
any immersive sim maybe in any video
game ever
but you can see the way i agree
fine whatever i mean cracking this lab
going simultaneously through time you
can see
um obviously it came out the same year
as titanfall 2's
but it's just really cool the way you
can see that
powers you can see level time and it's
also
the game has so much style it has such a
well-crafted world and that world has
lore
and they did such a great job with prey
um obviously we're buggy on launch time
i was there with you throughout the
review process i know you had your
struggles with prey
but looking back on it it's a really fun
game and
you know they tried a little bit extra
with the drop in dropout co-op of
wolfenstein youngblood
and all of this is what i'm hoping is
just going to accumulate
into death loop which i mean i have
spoken to death about how much i'm
excited for that game
it is my like at this point i think i'm
more excited for
death loop than i am for something like
cyberpunk or assassin's creed which is
huge for me because i love both of those
like i'm i'm so into cd projekt red i
love assassin's creed but honestly death
loop is like
my you can bleep that if you want
but so honestly if you want to like
get us hyped for death food but i am go
back to dishonored 2 go back to the
amazing dlc
which had such a cool storyline and no
one probably played it
because they're you know not doing
anything with dishonored at the minute
it's a fantastic game
to it alright so those are our
recommendations for games you might have
missed from this generation while we
wait for the next
uh join us again next week uh we'll be
here breaking down all the biggest news
stories and let us know which games you
think
you should pick up from this generation
if you haven't already and let us know
what you're playing either in the
comments below
on the gamespot discord message one of
us for an invite it's a very fun
chill place we're all very excited about
gaming in there understandably
um or come tweeted us all uh tam where
can people find you
gushing in yharnam that's where you can
find me can you stop singing
and concluded with that i'm on twitter
i hate that this is what we've booked
bookended
some other stuff big phil uh yeah
jordan incorrect companions about time
travel levels
but don't maybe take your plug away from
you jordan
where can people find you they can find
me at jm remain
where i talk about games with excellent
time travel levels like titanfall 2.
look i'm not dissing titanfall 2 okay i
love titanfall 2.
but the sonnet is better i'm on twitter
at lucy james games
we'll see you next week i respect that i
respect that russell
[Music]
[Music]
you